des images pour le moins déroutante en
déplacement à tain l'hermitage dans la
drôme emmanuel macron a reçu une gifle
de la part d'un homme le président
s'était approché d'un groupe de
personnes positionner est derrière des
barrières quand un individu l'a agrippé
avant de lui adresser un coup au visage
la préfecture a annoncé avoir interpellé
à deux personnes qui sont actuellement
en garde à vue mayol macron a tout de
même poursuivi sa visite après cet
incident le premier ministre a
immédiatement réagi à l'assemblée
nationale lors de la séance des
questions au gouvernement écouter à
travers le chef de l'état c'est tout
simplement la démocratie qui est visé la
démocratie la démocratie
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la démocratie et vous en est
l'illustration c'est le sait le débat
c'est le dialogue c'est la confrontation
d'idées c'est l'expression de désaccord
légitime
bien entendu mais ça ne peut en aucun
cas être la violence l'agression verbale
et encore moins l'agression physique
j'en appelle à un sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie je vous remercie jean castex
applaudi par les messies qu'un acte
largement condamné également sur les
réseaux sociaux l'opposition politique
et solidaire du président cette fois-ci
vous commencez à comprendre que les
violents passe à l'acte je suis
solidaire du président si le débat
démocratique peut être âpre il ne serait
en aucun cas tolérer la violence
physique
je condamne fermement l'agression
physique intolérable qui a visé le
président de la république
je condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
le geste inacceptable dont a été victime
emmanuel macron aucun des accords
politiques ne justifiera jamais la
violence le respect des institutions de
la république et de ses représentants
est en principe cardinal de notre vie
démocratique
exactement ce qu'est papa si tôt ça y
est vous la prenez au sérieux la
violence d'extrême droite maintenant
solidaire du président